Good morning Hank, it's Friday. It's question
Friday, the day that I answer real questions
from real Nerdfighers. Let's get right to
it.
Favorite joke?
Billy was a chemist's son, but Billy is no
more. What he thought was H2O Was H2SO4. Hey!
What's your take on the Oxford comma?
Lovely comma space, unintrusive comma space,
and absolutely necessary.
Can you cart wheel?
*attempts cart wheel*
No.
Who the F is Hank?
Hank is a city of just over 3000 people in
southern South Dakota known for it's pheasant
season.
Do you fit into those wooden shoes in the
background?
Kinda.
Other than heights, what are you afraid of?
Hmmmm...Geese, Mice, and oblivion.
What did you and Hank fight about when you
were kids?
We primarily fought about whether I should
be able to rewrite the rules of games we were
playing while we were playing them in order
to ensure my victory. I felt that this was
not only my privilege as on older brother,
but also my responsibility, where as Hank
was kind of a wuss about it.
John, how are you so cool for a nerd?
I don't agree with your premise and as evidence
for my case I would like to present you with
middle school me. Thanks for getting me those
glasses mom.
How can I find other Nerdfighters at my school?
My recommendation is to acquire or make a
DFTBA shirt.
What does DFTBA mean anyways?
It means Don't Forget To Be Awesome.
What would you name your puppy sized elephant?
I would call him Lewis and we would be the
best of friends.
How can I get all these old Nerfighter jokes
if I'm a new Nerdfighter?
If you listen to Hank's music, read my books,
watch some old videos, and hang around for
a while you'll get it all eventually.
How do you feel about the Kindle?
I don't really care how people read, I care
if they read.
Is your next book really narrated by a girl?
Yes.
Will you ever right another book with David
Levithan?
Maybe, but in the mean time you can just read
David Levithan's amazing new book that he
wrote by himself, The Lover's Dictionary.
Link below.
Favorite Mountain Goats song?
Raskolnikov felt sick, but he couldn't say
why when he saw his face reflected in his
victims twinkling eye.
What Mountain Goats album should I start with?
I forgive you for ending your sentence with
a preposition and present you with a recommendation
in the dooblydoo.
Will we ever see the Yeti?
I don't know, let me consult my edition of
Yeti Researcher volume 24 number 8. This thing
has ads. It has a snowmobile ad. I guess that
makes sense, I mean if you're going to be
finding the Yeti you might need a snowmobile.
Yea, no I don't think you're ever going to
see the Yet.
Would you date a girl more intelligent than
yourself?
Yes, in fact I married one.
Your headdesk was lame.
That's not a question, but thank you for your
constructive criticism. Hold on, I'll try
to do better. Ahhhhhhhh...Headdesk! *Headdesk,
followed by sigh and other noises* Ohhh, excessive
headdesk.
The rest of today's video will be performed
while concussed.
Is the world going to end in 2012?
I excessively headdesked and now I don't remember
your question.
What is the purpose of a water tower?
I used to know the answer to that; it involves
gravity, but then I excessively headdesked
and forgot.
What's your middle name?
I don't know, is today Tuesday? Did I hit
my head earlier?
How old are you?
Why am I sitting in front of a video camera?
When will your zombie apocalypse novella be
finished?
Hopefully within a week or so, it's terrible
and I want to finish it so I can go back to
my real book, but I need some zombie killing
scenarios. So if you know of any can you please
leave them in the dooblydoo?
Hank there are a bunch of other questions,
but I think I actually gave myself a concussion,
so I will see you uhhh...Man, that, yea...Monday,
I will see you on Monday.